m brigitte lahaye si vous voulez bien
vous asseoir sur ce coussin un rose que
jean cazenave vous a préparé
voilà alors vous j'ai dis donc en
supplément au programme je vous ai
invité parce que vous êtes donc
considéré comme la star du cinéma
pornographique et vous racontez vos aux
éditions fie aux éditions philippe
active des souvenirs sous le titre moi
la scandaleuse quand vous dites moi la
scandaleuse et scandaleuse aux yeux des
autres mais pas à vos yeux pleins de
joie de bonne humeur et d'amour alors
combien de films érotiques ou
pornographiques avez vous fait j'en ai
tourné une quarantaine entre 76 et 80 à
l'époque où c'était l'âge d'or du film x
en france
j'ai eu la chance de tourner dans un
très bon film oui et si vous avez fait
dans quarante films c'est pas contrainte
et forcée
c'est parce que vous aviez ça c'est
parce que j'aimais ça et que je me suis
complètement épanoui et kimi ça m'a
apporté énormément de choses qu'est ce
que ça vous ça m'a appris à m'aimer
d'abord parce que parce que en arrivant
à paris j'avais 18 ans je me trouvais
très laide et je crois qu'une femme pour
s'aimer elle a besoin de se sentir
désiré est bon c'est peut-être une façon
un peu absolue de se sentir désirable en
tout cas ça m'a jamais convenu très très
bien mais est ce qu'il y a un plaisir
différent à faire l'amour devant une
caméra
par rapport à une relation charnelle
dans l'intimité ce que c'est différent
bien sûr vous avez un facteur
supplémentaire qui vont pour quelqu'un
d'exhibitionnistes qui excite beaucoup
plus et puis peut-être que le fait de
savoir filmer
on pouvait peut-être encore plus que
j'étais finalement désirable que si
j'avais été simplement avec un seul
homme mais quel plaisir on sent vraiment
un plaisir particulier à ce moment-là
essayé je veux dire que j'aurais du mal
à trouver un producteur qui me donne de
l'argent
vous dire il ya dans les dents les
ardeurs quelqu'un avec qui j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
oui c'est comme ça qu'on appelle les
comédiens qui tourne ces films là je
vous assure vous avez vraiment un sosie
vont s'en moquera bon peut-être mois
qu'en savez vous oui bon alors est ce
que dans votre vidéothèque vous avez
tous vos films
non j'ai quelques signes que j'aime
particulièrement mais je ne les regarde
pas je préfère les avoir tourné à
mouvoir mais ce que vous n'aimez pas
vous regarder
alors aujourd'hui vous ne tournait plus
dans des noms aujourd'hui je tourne des
films traditionnels comme vous c'est
embêtant jolie tournée des petits rôles
dans des films y ou z alors que vous
étiez vous tourniez de grands rôles dans
des films x
ils ont qu'actuellement je tourne des
grands rôles dans des films de série b
alors maintenant on va laisser passer à
la seriat bon vous là dans ce livre vous
mettez à nu alors vous êtes souvent mise
nue mais cette fois vous le faites avec
des mots alors pourquoi mais c'est
encore plus dur de toute façon de se
mettre nu avec des mots je les fais part
d'abord pour moi même pour essayer de
vraiment me comprendre un peu mieux
et puis ensuite parce que parce que les
gens ne comprenaient pas les gens la
tendance à penser que à partir du moment
où on est très exhibitionniste on est
forcément nymphomane ou complètement
obsédé donc je voulais montrer que
j'étais également une femme pudique il y
avait du coeur et je crois que le
meilleur moyen de leur montrer c'était
d'écrire le livre fameux pu dit que
vraiment vous croyez pas ce que je vous
raconte et quand même que vous avez
participé à toutes les parts tous
parisienne à la fin des années 70 vous
raconter tout ça quand même ensuite oui
mais c'est bon masse et des anecdotes
c'est des fesses des sensations ces
données sensibles en plus de leurs la
pudeur de quoi de oui mais pour faire
pour faire comprendre aux gens ce que je
suis vraiment il fallait il fallait
aller ça lui dire la vérité je peux pas
être passé sous silence le par tout ce
que j'ai fait
qui finalement quelque part faisait
aussi partie de ce besoin de sentir
aimés et désirés et demander à mes côtés
je tombe vous
de qui des partenaires dont 70 des
nombreux et bien sûr dans leur gîte et
gt gt amoureuse et d'un homme dans ma
vie que j'ai beau se mêlant plusieurs
elle vous êtes tombé amoureux du nord
oui oui vous avez une ans maintenant
vous n'avez jamais rien actuellement 6es
vous êtes à regarder lui
est-ce que vous avez prouvé sur des
vélos si vous n'avez pas au lui
regardez vous parce que les hollows et
non à l'époque l'homme qui me l'homme
qui n'aimait qui m'emmenait d'ailleurs
dans ces soirées spéciales que l'on
appelle par tous étaient très fiers
finalement de ce que je faisais et ça
l'excité donc plus chaudes et alan hippe
unitaire a dit si williams etc et vous
voilà il était amoureux de boer oui un
jour non mais qui ne sont plus ensemble
nous marier et des enfants et est ce que
le mot indécence un sens c'est un très
beau mot pour moi toute façon à 10 ans
et je crois que je crois que ma manière
c'est vrai que je choque c'est vrai que
je suis peut-être indécence indécente
pardon mais c'est ma façon d'exister je
vous mets peut-être trouvé vous à
descente ma question c'est vrai chez
tout juste
j'ai pas où vous le dire mais c'est
andré pieyre de mandiargues qu'est-ce
que quel est votre sentiment quand vous
voyez cette femme qui avec beaucoup de
franchise beaucoup de 10 voilà ce qui
s'est passé parce que j'aimerais
beaucoup le faire mais très sympathique
mais voyez-vous de leur honneur à tous
questionnaire comme ce titre en train de
se passer en ce moment ça me fait penser
que le reste unie traitance
et qui devrait proposer et la phrase
qu'isabelle la mort invoquait
qu'isabelle d'est faisait inscrire
partout sur les murs du palais de
mantoue français qui s'ils pensaient
qu'enel peut-être que oui
l'intellectuel est alors j'ai vu que
cécile saint laurent qui vous a procuré
vos premiers émois sensuelle diable
d'homme alors fait qu'elle ait mis
française maintenant c'était caroline
chérie wiki malaise alors vous parlez de
bon des relations charnelles vous a vu
en dehors du petit écran quand je vois
que les écrivains sont pas très forts
alors vous parlez de cet écrivain
obscènes et prétentieux je sentais
thébaux - après cette autre romancier
galant courtois jamais très à l'aise
dans l'intimité de mauvais souvenirs des
écrivains ça changera peut-être soir
choisissez lancé
si albert haut niveau n'avait pas
compris mais madame l'aise projette d'en
partir avec vous après cette émission
non ne met pas d'accord a souvent noda
s'est alors ysabelle lacamp qu'est-ce
que vous que vous êtes comédienne aussi
oui alors est ce que vous pourriez
tourner dans des films comme ceux ci non
mais c'est bon en tout cas je trouve que
c'est un livre qui a une super pêche et
beaucoup d'humour super pêche ils râlent
et des légumes entre les états fois ci
alors aux métaphores jardinières un
potage heures s'il parlait de
effectivement de bonne humeur de bon et
puis elle s'est mise à nu il se trouve
que c'est c'est un niveau si touchants
et elle a bien montré qu'elles étaient
sincères et une femme deux cherchent
c'est pas comment alors je donnais
dernier mot et bein sûr aux caisses vous
pensez du temps je continue dans le
potager je dirais qu'en plus elle a de
la fraîcheur et que c'est inattendu
sortant de tous ces travaux parus le
garder de la fraîcheur
espérons qu'elle vous reste rallonger la
fraîcheur du coeur c'est trop merci
alors l'heureux d'un comité mode vous
l'offrir le ricanement diable